[Music]
how does this look
hey guys
[Music]
it doesn't do its justice how big it is
welcome everyone to the y
leave your memes on the reddit 19 year
old now
measure your pee pees on the next
episode of hawaii
tambourine let's check out the memes
i love memes fifty dollars and i'll do
whatever you want
can you hold my fan art women am i right
someone needs to make that youtube video
where they just draw a bunch of
the art and they would just pay some hot
girl to hold it for them
to see does it work does it work
i need to know can't really see this
tambourine
but it's it's on the floor it's a big
one but
i can't see the memes good morning if
something bad happens today just
remember that at least you didn't lose
an
island because you weren't subscribed to
pewdiepie wait what
someone lost an island
what happened in his most recent video
someone lost a chance to win a 7
pound island because they weren't
subscribed
no all right i guess i'll have to go to
mr peace
this is the one i bought this entire
island and now it's time for the most
important subscribe test are you
subscribed
let's do it if you're not subscribed you
have to leave the island
oh my god he knows he knows
oh no that's what you
did you continued to the next round
i'm really bad at this but you don't
this isn't even your channel
ethan buddy it was tragic
he lost because you weren't subscribed
if that's not a good reason to subscribe
to this channel
right now you could win an island
literally
can we talk about the fact that mr beast
gave away a [ __ ] island
how does he
legit is impressive he's pushing
boundaries on youtube that no one even
knew there was
i love that so [ __ ] dope if you
haven't subscribed to mr beast
with bell notification on then you will
never get a tambourine out of me
huh do you understand oh cyber is a sim
in fact bell delphine wanted car to
contact pewdiepie inside
took the bullet
maybe psy was hero all along maybe psy
was hero
now he's seen now he's saved sorry side
i couldn't explain it better wait so has
the subreddit just changed their mind
now that xiv is not a sin
save us time please thank you
oh look at that maybe cyber's on the bad
not bad after all
wow
yeah he's a simple pewdiepie cringe
he's still simp come on come on
matzia for our first anniversary i got
you a gift
oh my god that's foreshadowing right
there
this is literally done before i got all
the time raids that's amazing
well done well done a prophet blanche
draw you're a prophet you're a goddamn
prophet
me after realizing that minecraft series
started a year ago
no ricardo no
oh god has it already been a year
has it seriously been a year how did
they just poof
what that's crazy petitioned for media
to use this picture of felix instead of
that trashy one
as his default picture yes where i look
like an anime villain
i look like the character at the end of
the film so you defeated the final bar
say
well i have a secret mission i need to
instruct you on
the tambourines we must combine them all
into one
giant tambourine dude glue works so much
better i'm gonna glue all of these later
glue gang wins tape
pathetic glue for life
glue gang if you're not glue gang get
the hell out of here
i gotta try something
[Music]
no what just happened
stupid tape sucked dude what the hell
i thought i need to glue i need to glue
i need glue
oh stupid tape useless
what has happened to my videos at some
point i swear we were normal
when pewds ask for more uh but you don't
want emojis to be part of the loop
he drew them away all right the loop
continues
yeah but now you just doxed your feet my
dude
ah that's a yikes sorry man you just
gave away any sort of chance
you had to have a tier 3 sub you
basically just gave away prime real
estate my dude never show feet
everyone knows this oh for a happy first
wedding anniversary put a lot of effort
into this that looks amazing
and it was posted on our anniversary
that's so nice
huge peepee thank you thank you latvinia
even got the cherry blossoms i love it
no
[Laughter]
amazing fan art that took a ton of
effort
this
another great banner that's so cool
thank you oh my god
it's black james charles holy [ __ ]
twitter i'm about doing this whole main
career
try me twitter i'm not on your shitty
website anymore what are you gonna do
it's like screaming into a void you
ain't got nothing on me
nothing twitter you real you have no
power you just a bunch of whiny [ __ ]
i'm not a girl but i
have a little hope of this working
that's a cool drawing there my dude
that's some big peepee right there
welcome to the sub kid
we got simp holding fan arts yep
all right someone summarized the whole
subreddit all right let's
let's get it the same finishing for me
hey come on that was a good one shut up
cocomella intros i mean those are cool
something nobody asked for yet whatever
you see in there
the future all those things yep yeah
that's it
could be worse yeah literally took the
words out of my mouth i wouldn't have it
any other way
you forgot the tambourine memes you
dumbass
not big people you get small pee pee
uh no it keeps
i should have been glue gang i was
greedy i wanted to save time
five stages of grief stage one denial
i'm not the simp
look at this side look at this anger
bargaining
depression how do i unzip myself except
okay i simply
oh i'm glad you were finally able to
come in terms with
the reality of this situation
i tried to punch a hole in it couldn't
do it think i can do it
you think i could do this you call me
you call me a simp
oh yeah ah
it's fine it didn't hurt he didn't hurt
it can't hurt if i can't feel
therapists stonks man doesn't exist he
can't sing to you oh
no oh damn that's well animated
beautiful my songs are rising time
travel gets invented
girls oh my god i can't wait to see my
younger self boys
i just wanted to be here for this moment
the real reason for time travel just
experience different times in history
imagine not winning a private island
because you're not subscribed to petey
that face what a beautiful image
that's hilarious marcia and felix
reposting and adding until
peter sees p3 so close to posing with it
because i don't know what to add
oh [ __ ] we got the whole crew in here
damn why am i so short why am i
i will you will break one day you
understand
whoa ahead go
it keeps going it keeps going
no that's my dad stop it no
no ah
stop no no
who's on top of the chain no
it keeps going mike
oh oh oh
[Music]
it's all fan art
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] off you were so good i was going
to give you big pp and everything
now i have to small ppu
council of tambourine have spoken small
pp
sorry you you made me do it who am i
going to
pp small next yeah can't wait to find
out
damn oh my gosh stop doing with the leg
that's not i have a torso it exists okay
i swear i swear i have a torso guys
oh god now everyone's going to draw my
head never
damn hell yeah unfortunately
i'm not an enemy girl i can relate
and i don't have money to hire one
very big peepee huge huge
only 39 million cringe mr beast oh
dude if anyone i'm sure that's gonna
overtake in subs and i'm i'm
completely fine with it is mr beast
give it a year but if i have to make it
this track if you come close enough mr
peace
i love you don't come near me this will
be your pp all right
imagine this your pp right
simp actually stands for sai being my
president seif is my president and this
whole meme is an
elaborate scheme to announce he is
running for president cypher for
president
all right elbow i'll vote he can reduce
taxes on youtube videos right you can
yeah it's a deal yeah floor gag
nice that's amazing banner thank you so
much
huge pp what would happen if marcia
inhaled about helium balloon
that's i'm charlie and the chipmunk [ __ ]
this is the happiest memory in the brain
i'll play it every time we get sad good
meme big beep
another good meme big baby hey we got
more intro
never stop the intros okay you
understand
you understand me
[Music]
whoa how does this look hey guys
that's so unexpected i love it pete's
saying you have big peepee
the girl's saying you have big pee pee
your girl saying yeah big thing why
would you care
yeah that's right big pippy
the broken peepee you got broken people
it's perfect again
you have a huge appeal
i can't believe we're still doing the
peepee joke it's been so long
me when pierce gives him a baby which
yes cyanide and happiness
very nice peers i don't want to take
pictures with fans understandable have a
great
thanks for understanding can you sign my
tambourine i guarantee you
if you come to me with a tambourine i
will sign it with my p
and i will sign it i will bl i won't
sign it that's lame i will bless it i
will bless your tambourine
if you need me to do it i'll do it for
free
if we don't post memes for two to three
weeks pewds will be forced to make
original content
like that's ever gonna happen oh yeah
did you see my tambourine building video
[ __ ]
you ain't seen nothing like it [ __ ]
another one
oh i feel my heart thank you
dope holy [ __ ] my wife's first attempt
designing a shirt all right all right
i i contacted you a pink one for variety
i love it
i'll pay you i'll pay you let me sell
this and i'll pay you
oh it took me a while big
pp
i'm so confused big bp
well done nice yo what the [ __ ]
y'all what the [ __ ] dad yeah
check out simp merch before scy buys all
of it
the tambourine we'll we'll set we're
selling tambourines as well
all right soon
me after seeing the hunters pose the
calling cyber shim shut the f
please shut the [ __ ] oh yeah nice meme
side you think i'm gonna fall for this
small pp another
intro i love it
[Music]
wait what oh it's a girl holding the
intro got it
okay
i love when people are like the simps
the ship meme is so run to the ground
all the kids online ruined the simp meme
now like anyone doing anything with a
girl
is called a simp it's so crazy yeah
that's the point that's a joke
you get it now congratulations do you
understand the joke congratulations you
want the applause
the joke is that it runs to the ground
get it
it's funny it's [ __ ] funny i don't
care what y'all say
never be nice to woman i'm done
respecting them from now on
you even think of woman
you understand next meme
hey did case i get a flute yet because i
get a flute yet
me unconsciously singing for the latest
intro for lawai
my mom you let someone measure your what
yes yes yes yes yes
[Laughter]
good meme good meme so that's how he did
it huh
that's how we afford that no
i missed this tomorrow
will be felix for that
god damn it we were so close mr story
imagine having arms this post is made by
no armed gang
no arms gang tambourine floor gang glue
gang
that's what you are if you're not one of
those
doors yeah edgar skin
yes oh no what is this it's a keyhole
yeah
all right what do we got today boys what
have we got what is that what is the
prophecy for tell
this this day what do we got
huh what do we got what are you seeing
[Laughter]
playing animal crossing once building a
tamarind tower to the moon
it's happening we're almost there step
by step process my dude
you got to keep walking you never give
up you can never fail
i am building a tambourine to the moon
because i'm still
doing it and i haven't given up doing
the heather i'm building it to the moon
nasa be like bro two men
wear watermelons on their head while
stealing from a convenience store
i knew it they need to be stopped dude
coco melon is at 90 million now we're
running out of time they say no joke
this ain't no game yo i made a looping
animation for periods
that's so cool damn huge dick
after putting two dirt over everywhere
letter in your past swinsky
time travel gets invented oh my god i
will meet my younger self
gamers don't make sven freak his son
don't touch dj cow don't use magma keep
on water shape
don't make jargon to ride the roller
coaster
edgar noises agent e is here felix
agent e you're here dr pewdiepie is
working on that tambourinator
so stop him did i forget something my
dear no felik
i am how did how did you know this yeah
yeah i'm building a tambourine to the
move
to the moon from pepe and beyond
my peepee will touch the moon yes yes
yes yes uh me and my room imagining fake
scenarios and hurting my own feelings
what the [ __ ] you guys do this
who has time for this [ __ ] god damn
that's cringe congrats pewdiepie on his
marriage we all wish you a happy and
loving life
thank you internet browser
can gay people stop generalizing gay
people just kidding
i like to add a just kidding at the end
of jokes now in case they're ever played
in
car
yep welcome to try and make jokes in
that this is the new rules can i take a
picture
19 year olds video can i shake your head
no no i can bless your tambourine
don't ever approach me without a
tambourine in your hand that's all i'm
gonna say
no this i saw this this never made it
why it's beautiful
it's glorious i feel so powerful in this
you know
[Music]
nope
no no stupid tape gang it doesn't work
i just thought about this yeah gay
people can't be simps
so i know what i have to do but i don't
know if i had the strength to do it
come on shy come on you know what you
got to do
i look like a cute anime mark zuckerberg
i love it
thank you so much andrea phillips is gay
proof he has a wife his wife likes guys
what is gay than marrying someone who
likes guys
well i guess that means i'm not a sip
then i'll take it
[Laughter]
i knew that thumbnail was not going to
get enough views
but i knew it would be worth it in the
end
hey someone made connectivity nice
i hope it was good of course it was
connected brother lish
all right gamers that's the end of the
episode of the y
see you next time i'm gonna go and glue
my glue my tambourines
glue gang ow thank you for liking
subscribing and all that crap
and i see you guys on the flippy floppy
[Music]
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean